من حيث شدد رئيس مجلس اسياد عبد الفتاح
البرهان خلال لقائه رئيس الوزراء
الاثيوبيه ابي احمد في الخرطوم على ضروره
تعزيز التعاون والتنسيق بين البلدين واكد
البرهان خلال جلسه مباحثات بين الجانبين
ان الخرطوم وادي صبابا متوافقتان ومتفقتان
بشان جميع القضايا المتعلقه بسد النهضه
وقال بيان المشترك سوداني اثيوبي ان زياره
باحمد الى الخرطوم
للوقوف مع حكومه وشعب السودان في ازماتها
الحاليه بما يفضي الى تحول الديمقراطي
والوصولي للانتخابات
نحن اتفقنا في كل الامور كلما نقشناه من
امر لم نجد اي اختلاف او اي خلاف في اي من
امورنا وهي كلها نريدها ان تصب في مصلحه
الشعبين لتقويه هذه العلاقه بين الدولتين
الجارتين الشقيقتين نحن سندعم ما تم من
توافق في خاص بيقليم وسنزع الى ان همم
تكون علاقتنا الجواريه ومصالحنا المشتركه
هي ما يحفزنا وهي ما يقودنا الى ان ابني
مستقبل سعودينا